earlier this week governor steve sisolak
announced that hundreds of nevada
national guardsmen will remain on duty
they've been helping at kova test sites
across the valley now for quite a bit of
time hector mejia is live in front of
texas station
with details on this hi hector
hey there alex good morning and they
open at eight o'clock this morning
offering free testing on a first
come first served basis and if you take
a look right behind me you'll see
drivers already lining up 90 minutes
before this facility even opens we've
seen long lines extending
from the parking garage out to the
casinos parking lot
and if you've been tested before chances
are you've seen soldiers at sites across
the valley
since april hundreds of nevada national
guardsmen have been playing a critical
role in the fight against the virus
this week governor steve sisilak said
they'll stay on duty at least
through the end of march of 2021. this
has been the largest
and longest activation in the state's
history troops are also
in rural parts of nevada traveling and
providing tests
throughout the state i've told our
soldiers and airmen
is that they are part of history in
their response to this pandemic it's
hard to prepare for something that no
one is ready for
so everything is constantly changing
constantly evolving every day
testing is recommended even if you feel
healthy the centers for disease control
and prevention says
symptoms may appear anywhere between 2
and 14 days after exposure to covid
some people never develop symptoms but
are still contagious and again this
facility opens
at eight o'clock this morning offering
free testing and we looked up the
state's website
this morning that tracks testing and it
says the positivity rate increased this
week
it's now 18.1 percent reporting live
hector mejia
8 news now